everyone did an oopsie
*pew news intro*
my name is GlooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
oooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
o o o o o o oo
*O I N T E N S I F I E S*
-ria Borger
and you're watching the most respectable news site outlet of all time
that is not our personal bias, that is just
Straight up
F A C T S
Now some news for-
*dramatic close up*
A lesser media outlet
Buzzfeed, everyone
H A
patheticc-
Buzzfeed prints a one-off magazine!
♥ w o  o w ♥
That's incredible!
Wow how innovative! (Truly innovative)
Going back to print, what a great idea! (Captions agree)
And put-
M O M O
on the cover.
This is phenomenal work, Buzzfeed
Good job Buzzfeed you really did-
you really outdone yourself this time Buzzfeed
Can I sound a little bit more condescending?
So this was on my Twitter news feed for some reason
Twitter decided "hey you wanna know about this?"
BUZZFEED EVERYONE
Its a-
And I love all the responses to this basically
*N O  O N E  C A R E S*
(noonecares.mp4)
Good call moving to print! Booming industry!
So you're telling me that the creative director said:
"When history looks back at Buzzfeed's #1 issue,
we want the iconic MOMO to be on the cover..?"
Well well well, to bad there wont be any history for Buzzfeed
I know, this is so sad
Last month it was reported that as many as 2100 people have lost their jobs in the past two weeks
Buzzfeed having a cut of 15% of their staff
This is SO. SAD. ok
I'm not giving my opinion, but I'm literally shaking and crying right now
Buzzfeed, who hires such amazing people like Joe Bernstein-
Oh, god no!
NOOOOOOOOOOO-
*smac*
*SmAc*
*S M A C*
Oh and not vice too, Vice!
Laying off 10% of their workforce?
Vice, that does such incredible journalism..
This is a huge blow for journalism...
How are we possibly going to survive?
Now, obviously people losing their jobs is not to be celebrated
but...
*dramatic closeup 2 incoming*
B U T
Kinda hard to feel bad for companies, that are running these smear campaigns
Not just against me, but other people as well.
Are you suppos-
How long do they keep thinking they can do this kind of stuff without getting away with it?
Obviously there are many factors involved
But I find it ironic and funny how Buzzfeed two years ago after the wall street journal scandal,
uh, posted about my-my downfall
Writing: His downfall feels anti-capitalist, it feels nonconformist, it makes us feel all the things we love to feel to prove we're better than
Well
WELL
W E L L
what a downfall indeed
Have fun, Buzzfeed
I'll be laughing all the way
N E X T
(clap)
N E W S
Next news comes from Captain Marvel, that's right
y'all know I would talk about this.
the reason why I haven't done a few news in a while is
I haven't been too invested in what's happening
and it's been kind of nice to be honest
but this is one of those news that
uH-
you just can't- You can't escape
it's been literally everywhere, recommended in all the feeds
Rotten Tomatoes explains why it removed thousands of audience reviews on Captain Marvel's opening day
WELL
I don't even have to research this
DISNEY PAID THEM!!
that is not fact. that is just pure speculation
but it also
most importantly
is my opinion (which she's not supposed to have)
Basically, if you don't know what happened here
the Captain Marvel audience score review
on Rotten Tomatoes  was at 33%
and then a lot of reviews just disappeared and got deleted
some people were estimating over 50,000
and now it's sitting at 55% like ratio.
Now, however still enjoys Marvel films
you know
that's up to you, but
a lot of people define this as 'trolls', you know
this is trolls and therefore, we have every right .
remove the review
if you're a troll then your opinion doesn't count, basically
ah, yes! Trolls! That's a good excuse to remove freedom of speech!
iF yOu'Re A tRoLl,
ThEn YoU'rE nOt AlLoWeD tO vOiCe YoUr OpInIoN!
mm-mm-mmh!
This s**t annoys me so much because it reminds me
of the goddamn Amy Schumer thing
I don't know if you remember her Netflix special
which was one of the worst things I've ever watched
and I watched that with an open mind
5% liked this film according to Google users
After the bad reviews came out
on Netflix from the Amy Schumer special
they removed the 5 star rating system
which now makes it impossible to find something
that you actually like on Netflix.
I've just given up tryna find stuff on there
Rotten Tomatoes said that it was a bug
🐛A BUG 🐛
that removed 10,000 audience reviews
Okay, Rotten Tomatoes, sure. Sure.
Are we expected to believe this?
Now, you might ask yourself, why?
Why was it getting bad reviews in the beginning?
Well, some people obviously liked the film
Some people described it as bland
and not that interesting and I mean
considering how many Marvel films they've done at this
point, it's probably kinda hard
to innovate. Personally
I think a lot of people disliked this film
becuase of the main charac- the main
actress, Brie Larson
who is probably one of the most unlikeable lead
female characters I've seen in a long
time. I mean , just-
and one more question. Um, what does it
mean to be a woman in film?
..........
it means it's really hard ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
........ and if you're a woman of colour,
then it's really, really hard ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
God, everyone just wants to be a victim, don't they?
Imagine being the lead- the lead of a...
multi million- what is it? Like
500 million- what was the budget
for this- IT DOESN'T MATTER
and then say it's really hard (giggles)
Imagine being attractive
being paid millions and then
going 'iT's So HaRd'. Like,
Jesus Christ. Imaging being
the figure of female
er- strong character and going
'it's really HARD' ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) JESUS CHRIST
What's ironic about this whole situation
about reviews getting removed is that
Lee Brar..er.. Larson herself
in the past expressed that
she doesnt like the way the
system of reviews is done because
a movie that she
like- what was it? A Tangle In Time
or something? What's it called?
A Wrinkle In Time ! ...got bad
reviews. Her response to that was basically
'well, it wasn't made for you'
67% of white men
are making these reviews
That's why it got bad reviews
because it wasn't made for white men, okay?
They've released findings
*SCHNIFF*
...that 67% of the top
critics reviewing the
100 highest grossing movies
in 2017
were white males.
Less than a quarter were white women
and less than 10% were
unrepresented men
only 2.5% of
those top critics were women of colour.
It's important to know
the fact here that Brie Larson
doesn't hate white men
- and I'm also saying
I don't hate white dudes! I'm just sayin
I'm not suppOSED TO GIVE MY OPINION
but I'm just saying...hehehe
Am I saying that I hate white dudes?
No... I'm not.
Let me try and unwrinkle this
she... hates white dudes or-I...
I--er-- I just- eh
I don't understand
and for the 3rd time, I don't hate white dudes!
Whether you agree with her or not, I think
her politics is what muddled
people's opinion
about her, at least and I think that's fair.
you know, not everyone wants politics
in everything and that-see... it's getting
kind of annoying at this point.
I think what annoys me most out of all this
is the strawmanning of
'if you didn't like this
film, then that means you're a troll.'
or that you don't like seeing strong
female characters or yada, yada, yada
it's the same thing every time.
I stumbled upon this footage, for example
There are people who get very bent out of shape
about the fact that she's a woman
...that Brie's a woman and wants
to see women moving into an equal
place in humanity to men.
sad. must be sad to be that
kind of dinosaur wandering toward
the tar pits.
AHHHHH
YES!
THAT'S why Alita: Battle Angel was getting so much
hate as well! That's when people are bent out of
shape over that movie getting released
or Wonder Woman
or literally hundred of female
main character films
No one cares. No one is making this arguement
that people don't want
equality or seeing strong female characters
or whatever it was he said
and wants to see women moving into an equal
place in humanity to men
or that women can move an equal place
aside the men.
NO ONE IS SAYING THAT
NO ONE
Maybe, like, a very small percentage
but of course anyone that- that
disliked this film
you just dont want to see women moving into
the same place
You know what? People dont realise
how hard it is being a female news anchor
but you dont see me complaining about it
Now for a 100 times more imoportant news
Dog showed up for storytime at
library but nobody came to read to him
Awwhawwahw
Unfortunately, nobody signed up
to read to Sting at the
White Bear Lake library
I'm shaking and crying
What? Felix, this news was posted
a year ago, why are you talking about this now?
it is 👏 still👏 relevant 👏  goddamnit
Uh, Forbs attacks Pewdiepie.
That's right!
They wrote this article saying:
"It's time to unsubscribe from Pewdiepie Vs. T-Series."
oKaY
ALrigHt
They're basically saying:
"Both channels have been irresponsible, prioritizing the attention growth of their channels
instead of helping to create a wHOLesoMe YOUtubE cOMmuniTy"
OWww...
Forbes just care about creating a WHOLESOME YOUTUBE COMMUNITY?
support the creators
The community is what got involved with this.
I didn't even start this whole thing...
*laughs*
It's the community that keeps it alive.
And they've done so many incredible things that I'm so proud of.
And the reason why they're bringing this up is because uhh...
A few days ago, it came up that
someone defaced a World War II memorial,
uhh, by writing "Subscribe to Pewdiepie"
This has been covered in so many different places
and obviously, it's jus- uhh,
it's disgusting
You know, I don't think I've done anything to...
...condone this sort of behavior.
Uhh, but of course Forbes...
...right-  right after
that, I've said: "A good meme for a good cause"
And that's sort of implying that, uhh-
They even wrote it straight out:
The creator hasn't made any efforts to temper the extremes of his fan base
What am I gonna do?
*Confuzzled*
Like, first of all, that's just not true
I already said in... many times
that, don't do anything (il)legal because that would obviously look bad on me
but doing this sort of hack- print hacks
*uH-*
people doing protests, people being- holding up signs
all these things are amazing and really fun to follow and i think it's really cool
no, i don't think i've done anything to condone this sort of behavior
obviously it's disgusting, obviously i don't condone it whatsoever
i don't know why anyone got in their mind to do this
it's just stupid
most likely it's just a kid
it looks like they just grabbed a stone to scribe it in and the mix of large and small letters kind of signifies that as well
uh it looks like it's many different kids
it looks like you could probably remove that pretty easily at least which im really glad 'cuz uh...
i would hate for that to be there
if anyone knows if it has been removed please let me know, it's just terrible, honestly
don't do this, i don't know i- i- it's like i'm expected to say don't do this
obviously don't do this, do i rea-  i shouldn't have to say it even
but of course, forbes has to go out of their way to *poof*
that's it for pew news, hope you guys enjoyed this episode
smash like, check out the merch
and i'll see you guys next time
gloria borger out
*borga borga boo*
*borga borga bye*
Tuber Simulator is now so relevant
That it's got a brand new minigame
Craniac
Drop the crane and get fresh items only available
in the washing machine-like game
And you say there's more?
Of course there is!
New knowledge perks
new quests
and new pixelings
and legs *legs intensify*
guys ....... legs
*ad for relevant game continues*